[Music]
my name is beryl
this is my new puppy asha and this week
we're looking at rice
[Music]
why rice so
after sugar cane and maize rice
is the most important commodity on our
planet
and this grain is versatile not only in
preparation but in form
there are so many different kinds of
rice
and they all taste different here are a
few examples
in china the world's leader in rice
consumption the main type of rice is
jasmine rice it's sweet and nutty and
tends to not stick together
in north america we have wild rice it's
nutty and starchy and chewy it can be
difficult to work with but
it tastes really good
in india they use basmati rice which
actually means fragrant in hindi it has
a floral and spiced aroma and is really
common in dishes like biryani my last
example is arborio rice from italy this
is the rice they use to make risotto it
is a rounded rice grain and it is very
creamy when cooked
[Music]
i had to change my shirt it got really
hot while i was filming
anyway
one thing is clear rice is a global
staple
and how people prepare it differs
greatly from country to country so
maybe you know the drill
i spoke to seven people
in seven countries to see different rice
dishes around the world so this
is the rice episode
in making this episode i decided two
things
one the rice needs to be a part of a
more complex dish so i'm not looking at
steamed or fried rice on its own
and two i want that dish to be a part of
a country's culinary identity something
that people care about
and my normal disclaimer i could only
film seven rice dishes so of course i
missed a bunch my favorite mango sticky
rice didn't even make the cut
so in the comments let me know where
you're from what kind of rice you eat
and what a great rice dish is because i
love reading the comments and learning
more
except for the comments about my
eyebrows what is up with that my
eyebrows are fine
anyway
let's get this rice train going
[Music]
on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
we're starting in south korea where rice
is the country's most valuable crop
this dish is actually only found in
korea and it takes a simple grain of
rice and completely transforms it
from
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
rice has been grown in africa for over 3
500 years and senegal is one of the
largest consumers of rice in all of
western africa
traditionally they use a kind of grain
called broken rice but this their
national dish uses jasmine rice
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in iran rice is a part of nearly every
dish in the cuisine and fun fact it's
not just the type of rice that's
important in iran but the age of the
rice many people there say that you
should store your rice for at least a
year before cooking with it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in finland potatoes rule over rice
however this dish is a savory rice pie
that is recognized as a specialty of the
country
[Music]
while
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
is
rice was introduced to mexico in the
1500s by european colonizers
however with that introduction came
these rice-based drinks that are now a
staple in the country
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
known for its beautiful wet rice patties
vietnam's mekong and red river deltas
are vital for rice production and this
dish which uses the natural color of a
magenta plant wows not only in flavor
but in design as well
[Music]
[Music]
that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you
in palestine rice plays a major role in
the cuisine including this specialty
dish that dates back to the 13th century
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
within this one word rice there is so
much diversity if i say that i'm eating
rice it can mean so many different
things
and you could never confuse one of these
dishes for another
they're all different in their own way
but rice is a global food for good or
for bad
and it's the basis of a lot of meals
that people gather around
friends family
it's a communal grain
and even though that grain is simple
people have found ways to make it
spectacular
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
is
foreign
foreign
you